this is what priti patel had promised
would be a thing of the past by now
the dangerous crossing by migrants and
refugees who often lose their lives in
the pursuit of reaching british shores
but this year more than 8 000 people
have made the journey
home secretary and her french
counterpart promised to improve on the
gains made by their joint intelligence
cell
the french will double the number of
police patrolling their 150 kilometer
coastline
to stop people making the journey in the
first place and to tackle the criminal
networks which facilitate them
they also promised a sophisticated
high-tech surveillance package
that includes drones radars and cameras
this they say will help the french
intercept and clear the area
before boats reach british shores priti
patel isn't exactly in
uncharted water here many previous home
secretaries have spent millions of
pounds trying to tackle the issue in
their own ways
so what makes this initiative different
we are now looking at the tactical
approaches that both the
french interior minister and i as home
secretary
are bringing in to absolutely go after
the traffickers by using law enforcement
tools
and obviously to make sure that we stop
the loss of life at sea that we have
seen this year
charities have warned against what they
say is the use of military solutions to
solve a humanitarian issue
the people who've suffered terribly and
they're coming to us for help
um all they want is for their asylum
claims to be heard and if there was a
way that they could do that without
making this journey
they would do it so it feels awful to me
that the response is
this sort of high-tech almost military
response
when they're just ordinary people french
authorities dispute the claim that
increasing evictions on their side is
forcing migrants and refugees to find
alternative homes you know the wish of
the migrants is so
so strong to get to your country
they have been crossing the
mediterranean sea
they have been facing so many problems
that when they arrive to our country to
the north of france
they can sometimes see your country the
white cliffs of dover
and they are ready to do everything to
try to cross
even with these little boats as a
further 39 people
entered the uk this way french
authorities said they prevented 63
others from making the journey
the home secretary will be hoping these
numbers remain in her favor
as she proposes a new asylum system in
the new year
sadia chowdhury sky news